we came here to give you the heads up
Barry
about what I met a human who goes by the
name King shark he's back and now he's
heading for Central City
cue the jaws soundtrack this thing is a
killing machine he's headed for the
docks let's do it we're gonna need a
bigger flash
hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my flash king shark trailer video
they're basically doing a nice riff on
jaws it's gonna be a lot of fun it's so
funny how that movie came out way before
I was born but I still hung those music
hues as a little kid in Cisco's line is
just so perfect we're gonna need a
bigger flash if you guys don't remember
the last time we saw King shark this is
the earth to king shark as far as we
know was at the end of episode four of
this season zoom sent him to earth one
to kill the flash but we know now the
zoom never intended for him to kill the
flash just to push the flash to his
limit so that he would become more full
of Speed Force that was when Harrison
Wells stepped out of the shadows saved
Barry but really just because he was
going after the earth two metahumans he
and team flash did come to an agreement
eventually but initially he came to
earth to to take down the metahumans
then later zoom gave him the ultimatum
if you don't help me steal the Flash's
speed force I'll kill your daughter but
what happened to king shark between
Episode four and now well it seems like
they kept him in an Argus prison and
king shark himself has shown up in a lot
of different titles like Aquaman he's
shown up during secret six
mostly Suicide Squad stories they
address his origins little during the
Aquaman comics his father is what is
known as the shark God although he might
not be an actual God he might just be a
really powerful metahuman it was even a
fun story when he went up against them
because his father is just a savage
creature and King shark is half human
the story of how he was born is actually
pretty trippy he wasn't created in a lab
he wasn't created in a dark matter
explosion or anything like that he was
born via natural birth what happened is
is that his father this shark God lives
on this island near Hawaii this really
remote he's so powerful that the locals
there worship Him as a god and leave him
offerings and sacrifices which include
women you can do the math on that that's
how King shark is half human he is
intelligent but he mostly comes off as a
big dumb brute that speaks in really
short sentences mostly used is relates
average comedy or WTF reveals like holy
[ __ ] it's a giant freaking shark that is
why I think this reveal on the docks is
gonna be so much fun with Barry just
putting his arms out wide we're gonna
dance let's go and then boom he just
jumps right out of the water they might
address his powers on the show he really
just has a lot of the benefits of sharks
like he regenerates tissue really fast
he's really strong really fast resistant
to cold he can breathe underwater
obviously he's part shark but beyond
that he doesn't have any really special
powers he doesn't have magic or anything
like that now because he's big
in an Argus prison since the end of
episode 4 Lila is now like the new
Amanda Waller she and Diggle are
crossing over to the flash that's why
they're doing the arrow crossover and as
you can expect there's gonna be a whole
lot of jokes about Diggle not being
comfortable around metahumans especially
the flash the last time Barry helped
Diggle Diggle threw up he peeks everyone
up and super speeded them away Diggle
just totally booted so expect some nice
tickle jokes actually I think in terms
of origin story the TV show is going
with what they did in the digital comic
if you guys didn't know there's a flash
season zero digital comic that
introduced the king shark character but
the way they explained it is a little
more in keeping with the way they
surfaced metahumans on the TV show he's
part man he's very sick the doctors
suggest this special treatment using
shark cells to help regenerate his
tissue but then the dark matter
explosion happens and boom you have
shark man now in that story that's the
earth one king shark but it's the earth
- king shark that we saw during episode
4 so I'm assuming next week they're
gonna explain which version of king
shark we're dealing with I always
thought the Harrison wells killed king
shark at the end of episode 4 but I
guess we'll find out and because they've
been getting rid of a lot of the Suicide
Squad characters on TV I know some of
you are wondering like why can they do
king shark if king shark is a Suicide
Squad character I don't know if King
shark is gonna be in the Suicide Squad
movie he might be there are a couple
surprised characters like there are a
couple actors who they haven't said who
they're playing because it's supposed to
be a big surprise I think Killer Croc
will be about as crazy as they get in
terms of animal people but it remains to
be seen he could totally be there and I
almost forgot the producers are talking
a little bit about stuff that happened
in last week's episode they did say
killer frost is coming back she's
totally not dead and they will explain
what happened after team flash escaped
she was using her powers to keep zoom
down he broke free and then stole Jay
Garrick and brought him back to earth -
Jay Garrick will still be alive they'll
find a way to get back to earth -
they'll have to open a new portal but
Jay Garrick and killer frost both coming
back obviously the man in the iron mask
is coming back - but the way they
explained it made it sound like we'll
see those characters before team flash
gets back to earth - but there will be a
lot more earth - stuff happening this
season so tomorrow new Game of Thrones
new Walking Dead be sure to subscribe to
get everything
there might be a few surprises we're
getting so close to Batman vs Superman
daredevil season 2 Captain America's
Civil War they've been dropping a whole
lot of random stuff so if anything
really cool happens I will totally make
a video for it well you
all that says to post you can click here
for this week's episode of the flash and
arrow if you haven't seen it and you can
click here for the Deadpool Saturday
Night Live Kanye West prank thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight